on se parle aujourd'hui d'un smartphone
de wow et pas n'importe lequel c919 le
29 mai la regarde juste ici sur la table
en grand c'est une vidéo qui est
réalisée aujourd'hui en partenariat avec
huawei pour vous parler du nouveau
format en faire un tour complet on va
essayer de comprendre plus que huawei
vous nous raconter comme histoire alors
je vous dis tout de suite tu arrives
dans la feuille 499 euros 99 ème rang
les marques ne veulent jamais arrondir à
500 euros on est quasiment à 500 euros
vous enlever un centime vous êtes 499
euros 99 regardez un peu ce que nous
raconte huawei avec ce no vengo qu'est
ce qui se passe qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire avec est ce qu'il est bon faut
tous après vous connaissez l'histoire on
se regarde ça tout de suite
[Musique]
on y croise un tour du côté du design
parce que c'est un truc qui m'a vraiment
interloqué quand on va où est venu me
dire tiens monsieur heureux on aimerait
bien faire une vidéo en partenariat avec
toi pour parler du nova 9 j'aurais dit
why not mais le nova 9 il me rappelle
vraiment à notre smartphone c'est le
honor 50 parce que oui de doc si vous le
regardez et lien on a vraiment le look
and feel duo nord 50 alors pourquoi
parce que si vous remontez quelques
temps en arrière jusqu'à ya pa très très
longtemps et bien huawei et au nord
faisaient partie du même groupe et il ya
une séparation au nord est parti à
prendre son indépendance est parti donc
forcément il ya un moment où on voit que
pour concevoir un smartphone il faut
passer un petit peu de temps il ya un
gros travail qui seul en amont ce qui
fait qu'il ya des choses qui sont
mutualisés et on va essayer le design
est vraiment été mutualisés avec leonor
5 ans pour autant ce qu'on a sous le
capot c'est pas la même chose est
différent donc autant il va se
ressemblent et notamment au niveau du
module photo sinon le reste c'est quand
même vraiment différent alors on va
regarder le design le premier truc qui
vous intéressait lorsque je les prie en
moins c'est je trouve les et ça c'est
cool il est léger et les fins et pas un
smartphone qui emma stone comme ça c'est
plutôt gagne si vous cherchez un petit
smartphone assez léger why not à côté de
ça il est quand même assez grand on a un
grand écran il ya tout ce que je trouve
vraiment sympa c'est au niveau du dos
alors là vous l'avez uniquement sur la
couleur bleue parce qu'il est dans deux
finitions vous avez soit un petit bleu
mat comme ça qui est très sympa vraiment
très joli avec le nova qui est écrit ici
à regarder l eau vais à nova assez
marrant ça vous l'avez uniquement sur le
bleu mat il existe également en noir si
vous le prenez en noir vous n'avez pas
cette écriture voilà personnellement
pour moi le coup de coeur ici tu sembles
vous avez ici un capteur d'empreintes
digitales vous connais vous posez votre
doigt il des verrous c'est pratique on
est quoi 02 secondes froid pour venir le
déverrouiller 03 secondes c'est
quasiment la même chose vous pouvez
également venir le déverrouiller grâce à
leur reconnaissance faciale de dégeler
pas mis je préfère le capteur
d'empreintes digitales mais si vous
souhaitez la reconnaissance sociale vous
mettez des rouges ces pratiques fabray
fonds connais l'histoire par contre bien
qu'il soit léger et bien qu'il soit fin
vous avez un très grand écran regardez
moi cette dalle elle est quand même
relativement énorme on veut se
rapprocher un petit peu c'est un écran
de 6,57 poussée du full hd + 2340 par
1080 alors le promettre de jouer tout de
suite c'est d'un point de vue logiciel
et bien je vous invite à me gratter un
peu dans les paramètres dès le départ
vous aidé en affichage et luminosité et
vous venez ici dans résolution de
l'écran pourquoi parce que par défaut
vous êtes en résolution intelligente ce
qui c'est qui va venir switcher entre
une résolution basse et une résolution
élevée résolution base vous êtes en hd
en 720p c'est pas ouf tandis qu'amd
élevé vous êtes en 1080p qu'est ce que
ça vient faire ici bien servir soutien
pour venir économiser de la batterie
alors me direz-vous est ce que vous
allez forcément voir la différence si
vous n'avez pas besoin de soutien en
résolution élevée why not je préfère
quand même moi ne m en résolution élevée
par défaut ça bien consommer davantage
mais ça me plaît d'ailleurs de la même
manière on va venir regarder ici vous
avez la fréquence de rafraîchissement de
l'écran qui se situe juste là ici on est
en dynamique à savoir qu'ici vous monter
jusqu'en 126 donc là on dynamique vous
êtes sur ce qu'on appellera un sens va
être adapté hâtif vous n'êtes pas tout
le temps en temps vers vous allez
switcher en 30 60 r est un 120 hertz
pour avoir effectivement je dirais le
rendu le plus équilibré et bien consommé
le moins de batterie de les laisser en
dynamique ça me conviendra lorsque j'ai
regardé une vidéo qu'elle soit au niveau
des aides c'est lorsque je viens
naviguer je suis sur instagram où je
viens jouer à des jeux qui nécessitent
jusqu'à 120 m et bien viendra switcher
automatiquement et ça je trouve plutôt
intéressante on vous voyez qui si vous
avez un taux de rafraîchissement qui va
jusqu'à 120 est retrouvé un plus à
l'écran hd r10 vous avez un taux
d'échantillonnage tactile 3 100 hertz
qui est plutôt bien pour venir jouer
pour du gaming why not on à 1,07
milliard de couleurs et puis on a un
écran incurvé alors je vois si vous le
verrez bien comme ça mais il est
légèrement incurvé sur le côté ce qui
vient ajouter un peu en profondeur parce
qu'il dérange pas brillé au niveau du
tactile c'est souvent le truc nouveau
décret autorise à des jeunes d'être là
et ben ça bouge pas c'est pas le bazar
le tactile il vraiment au centre donc je
me mets sur le côté il ya nos soucis ça
va très bien donc j'aime bien je trouve
sympa je trouve que l'écran est bien
fait bien maîtriser ces de l'oled on
connaît l'histoire à bruxelles doivent à
taux fixe elle est un ogre en termes
d'économie d'énergie ça rajoute un peu
plus en plus si vous avez de la
performance vous avez un snapdragon
778 j'ai les giga de ram 128 chica de
stockage on peut venir monter grâce à
une carte microsd jusqu'à 512 giga de
sokal c'est très classique mais pourquoi
il ya un truc qui a noté ici c'est que
le snapdragon 778 jay ne vous permet pas
d'avoir de la 5g et non vous avez la
kadji ici 4g hadji plus fade 5g la
question à se poser c'est est ce que
vous voulez en smartphones avec de la 5g
est ce que là ça que j'ai un truc qui
vous intéressent que ça vous intéresse
tout de suite fin 2021 début 2022 est ce
que ça vous intéressera en 2022 ils 23
parce qu'un smartphone comme celui-là
vous le prenez vous gardez minimum deux
ans il faut vraiment se poser la
question je pense que c'est vraiment un
élément important au niveau du choix
vous allez voir que l'écran fonctionne
bien au niveau l'espace multimédia
globale ça fonctionne on a un
haut-parleur monod à côté de ça vous
l'avez vu vous n'avez pas de prise jack
nul pas mais vous avez des buts ou 5.2
pour venir à péret des freebox par
exemple si ça vous intéresse why not on
a suffisamment de performance pour venir
faire tourner des jeux sans problème
dessus on a aussi une autonomie qui est
correct vous avez une batterie de 4300
millions de pèlerins et vous avez un
blog de charge qui est rapide c'est
marqué juste là je vaux l'ours et de
l'arche 1,66 watts donc c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on va moins venir se dire
tiens est-ce qu'il va durer une journée
mis 2 jours ce qu'on veut surtout dire
parce qu'avec un bloc de charge 60 6
watts lorsque vous avez un peu moins de
batterie vous venez vous le prenez vous
branchez vous rechargez je crois que
c'est de 0 à 100% en 38 minutes autant
dire que ça va vite par contre ça c'est
vraiment une astuces à connaître ne
descendait pas en dessous de 20 % au
niveau de votre batterie ne monte pas au
dessus de 80 % ça sert à rien donc vous
rechargez toujours dans cette fenêtre de
tir entre 20 et 80 vous prenez vous
brancher un petit quart d'heure et vous
êtes peinard vous êtes tranquille vous
avez parti pour suffisamment longtemps a
ajouté ici en plus que vous n'avez
absolument pas de recharge sans fil donc
si vous avez un petit chargeur cuisse ça
ne fonctionnera pas donc du coup non
plus pas de recharge l'inversé si vous
voulez venir charger à d'autres
smartphones dire charger des écouteurs
c'est pas possible mais le truc cool que
le bloc de changer les fonds dits pas
mal un autre point qui est extrêmement
important chez huawei c'est toute
l'expérience logiciel je vais pas vous
refaire l'histoire de huawei qui n'a pu
les gms alors je vous en ai parlé dans
une interview que j'ai fait de stéphane
turcot nakheel directeur marketing de
huawei france allait là bas parce que
c'est intéressant il fait un peu un
point sur yahoo gens sont tout de suite
dans l'évolution justement et bien
d'harmonie ou sdhc naissent également de
la galerie je vous mets le lien de la
vidéo quelque part par là c'est
vachement intéressant donc vous avez ici
ému à 12 on va venir retrouver le
catalogue d'applications de huawei qui
s'appelle la galerie ici on n'a pas de
place tort dans la galerie vous avez
plein de logiciels alors j'ai pas tous
voulaient faire passer les uns après les
autres ils souhaitent plus aller voir
cette vidéo elle est vachement
intéressant parce que ça vous montre
vraiment tout ce qu'on pouvait retrouver
je montre quelques petits programmes que
j'ai installé on va retrouver quoi bon
avoir soin du tic toc pour tous sortis
covit fatalement on a du snap chat qu'on
peut avec de la web a pu finir m youtube
mais c'est une webapp on va avoir vingt
minutes on a pas mal d'infos avec elle
c'est 0-1 voici pour vous montrer les
jeux pas trop clients ou ouest france on
peut avoir également le monde on a pas
mal de banques on a de la météo bout de
messenger pour s'envoyer des messages on
artega molotov télé bref y'en a un
paquet un paquet un paquet pas mal de
banques on a également bien michelin
c'est plutôt pas mal on va voir facebook
netflix sera une vidéo on n'a pas dit ce
n'est plus il faut le savoir asphalte 9
pour venir jouer spotify deezer bref y
en a pas mal voilà un peu ce que j'ai
installé la liste est non exhaustive y
en a beaucoup d'autres à venir découvrir
bien évidemment sur la binerie alors je
vous refais tout très rapidement s'ils
ne l'ont pas directement dans la galerie
vous pouvez retrouver été chargé les apk
ou faire des web apps c'est un peu
l'idée qu'on repose aujourd'hui ici donc
à pas mal d'applications ça se développe
de plus en plus et c'est intéressant
vous également pital maps et autres
applications de cartes où il va faire
des petits montages avec pétales clip
bref si vous cherchez une alternative
intéressante à se retrouvent ailleurs ce
que vous avez ici avec la galerie c'est
intéressant et ça se développe de plus
en plus et ça se développera de plus en
plus dans les temps à venir et je vous
le dis une fois de plus lorsque vous
achetez un smartphone aujourd'hui vous
ne partez pas sur un smartphone pour six
mois pour un an vous partez au moins
pour deux ans d'où le fait de savoir que
le catalogue d'applications l'app
galerie va continuer de se remplir avec
de plus en plus d'applications au
catalogue et ça c'est cool alors rien au
touquet vachement intéressant chez
huawei c'est toute la partie photo vidéo
hélas oui parce que huawei ils ont un
hardware de dingo et ça marche du feu de
dieu alors regardez vous avez quatre
capteurs et ouais ok le grand ici c'est
un capteur de 5 mégapixels en ouvre à f
1.9 capteur principal on s'en doutera
terral grand angle il est intéressant
pour plusieurs raisons première raison
c'est que vous avez une stabilisation
optique donc si vous bougez ça bougera
pas pour moi c'est cool au niveau des
capteurs est tombée une techno qui ont
intégré dans leurs plus hauts de gamme c
est ce qu on appellera le r y/y beyrède
yellow yellow blue qui leur permettra de
venir qu'après plus de luminosité
notamment vous allez faire des photos
conditions nuit donc ça c'est bien je
vous montre le respect des photos dans
quelques instants vous êtes également du
pixel baning compagnies regroupées 4
pixels en un habitat plus de capter plus
de lumière et c'est bien pour les photos
de nuit on peut bien filmé jean 4k à 30
images par secondes vous avez ensuite un
grand-angle de 8 mégapixels couvre f 2.2
avec un champ de vision de 120 degrés
est ici une ante et distorsions ça ça
évite d'avoir le bazar vous avez de
capteur de 2 mégapixels regarder hop là
de chaque côté ici vous en avez un quai
pour le bloquer pour le mode portrait
salle 2 mégapixels couvre f 2.4 et puis
l'autre c'est pour de la macro 2
mégapixels f 2.4 également en garde le
reste dans quelques instants puis vous
avez un petit flash est qui est là où
j'aime bien le côté
une photo la symétrie elle est très
sympa et vous avez bien évidemment une
petite caméra celle fille qui est
planqué juste la rda les lacets une 30 2
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.0 on peut
bien faire de la vidéo ici en cas de cas
jusqu'à 30 images par seconde et avec
les stabilisation électronique n'y a pas
de stabilisation optique ici à la vente
je vous montre les photos que j'ai pris
avec ce nova 9 alors regardez je voulais
tout de suite la météo n'était pas folle
le temps est relativement pas terrible
et c'est vrai quand on veut faire de
belles photos il nous faut la lumière là
ce n'est pas le cas donc on va pour des
raisons que tout ça qui nous permet
quand même d'avoir des tendances et de
voir un peu ce qui se détache alors on
regarde déjà là on est sur le
grand-angle on est sur notre caméra de
50 méga pixels bien évidemment la météo
n'est pas belle ça je vous le dis vous
le voyez pas ce que c'est là dessus
c'est pas mauvais mais il faut de plus
on manque vraiment de lumière pour venir
un chopper des petits détails en plus on
passe ensuite ici sur l'ultra grand
temps que c'est un poil plus marronner
mais ça fonctionne je vois pas de
déformation sur le côté ça me semble
plutôt correcte dans l'ensemble un peu
sur le maroni on le voit un niveau des
arbres colorimétrie pas le même et une
fois de plus c'est pas surprenant ici
oncle on va se rapprocher je vous ai
fait un x 2 bon c'est pas d'un
endettement on peut monter jusqu en faut
dix on va éviter on peut faire en faut
deux on va pas aller au delà de ça pour
ça va pas être terrible vu qu'on n'a pas
de télé objectifs ici la caméra de seul
fut somme toute est ce correct rien de
bien particulier à vous dire là dessus
j'ai fait de la macro j'en ai fait
plusieurs formes de débat c'est pas mal
une fois de plus je suis pas un très
grand fan de ces capteurs de maquereau
de 2 mégapixels mais on a quelques
effets rigolo et vous le verrez dans
quelques instants caméra grand angle
standard brand ça va mais la météo joue
dit en ce moment est vraiment pas où
donc c'est pas les meilleures conditions
on passe sur l'ultra grand temps que
c'est très cohérent ça fonctionne on
fait du x de hockey why notes et il faut
de plus souvent classiques ont fait dix
ans d'oubli quart d'heure macro alors on
avait fait un truc un petit peu rigolo
la nature est un peu figé il fait froid
à l'aide de faire quelque chose comme
-20 je propose quand j'ai été faire
toutes ces photos là c'est pas mal en
soi tout cas c'est rigolo qu'on sorte du
dickens et pas où vous voyez ça toujours
un effet un peu rigolo lorsqu'on voit
des plantes comme ça avec du gel dessus
petit problème ici de hautes lumières
mais il faut de plus c'est pas anormal
avec une caméra de 2 mégapixels riez les
toiles d'araignée qui sont complètement
gelée de tous les côtés ça donne des
trucs un peu rigolo et très très
graphique donc ça fonctionne mais on
voit voyez que sur le bois là et bien
c'est à s'ébruiter sait pas ou font une
fois de plus on va s'y attendre là
dessus le mode portrait fonction barack
trop trop mal il a du mal venir des
tours et c'est là où il faudrait une
petite caméra tough on le voit voyez
entre les doigts là c'est pas des tours
et il a du mal on le voit également on a
fait un autre et c'est ici là une fois
de plus des cons complexifie la scène
c'est un peu dur le contour du visage
par contre est pas trop mal dans
l'ensemble là je vous ai montré quelques
petites photos de nuit alors regardez
c'est pas mauvais une phase plus
indépendante de vos conditions j'aime
bien cette photo là je trouve très sympa
voyez on a bien toutes les lumières là
avec ses effets de profondeur qui est
assez sympa on a bien et lumière elles
ressortent bien on voit malgré tout la
sinne des abcès la nuit complète le
boulot et ça ne coûte vraiment vraiment
correct pareil ici avec les vélos ça
fonctionne c'est pas le meilleur
photophone enfin des photos de lui bien
évidemment mais ce qu'il vous sortira
c'est pas trop mauvais attention ici le
seul truc c'est que vous avez une
stabilisation optique sur le 50 méga
pixels mais quand même gaffe à pas trop
bouger moi vous savez c'est mon problème
là j'ai bougé la photo est pas où mais
si on fait attention globalement ça va
pas trop mal donc ce qu'il faut retenir
ici niveau la photo très clairement il
votre capteur principal de 50 méga
pixels y fera du boulot on peut faire
des trucs avec l'ultra grand temps c'est
pas parfait c'est pas dingue mais on
peut le faire automne et qui si vous
avez une vraie caméra qui intéressant
l'ultra grand temps que si on veut
pourquoi pas et tout le reste ça reste
quand même un peu gadget mais une fois
de plus à un petit peu moins de 500
euros c'est normal c'est un smartphone
qui a du wifi 6 du nfc pour le paiement
dématérialisé leur ici faut savoir qu'on
a pas non plus de certification ip67 ils
étaient 68 il n'est pas certifié étanche
et résistant à la poussière pour autant
s'il croise la poussière ou s'il croise
une goutte d'eau ça devrait aller ne
vous inquiétez pas il faut savoir une
certification elle se paye donc ils ont
préféré ne pas payer de certification
pour proposer un tarif plus attractif
c'est l'idée et comme on est dans
l'univers de huawei est une notion qui
est extrêmement important d'écosystèmes
vous en ai parlé une fois plus dans la
vidéo d'interview mais vous pouvez
découvrir au travers de différents
produits si par exemple vous avez un
moniteur bowe et vous avez un mec view
et bien pouvait venir faire communiquer
votre mail view directement un nouveau
smartphone on vous preniez votre iphone
s'affichera sur le mildiou si vous avez
de la même manière un pc de huawei
pouvait bien faire communiquer votre
smartphone avec votre pc vous faites du
mais roaring vous et votre smartphone
qui s'affiche dans votre pc dont vous
pouvez venir passer un coup de fil
directement depuis votre pc envoyer des
sms directement depuis votre pc faire
des copier coller et des glisser-déposer
mettre des photos bref les récupérer
c'est vachement bien fait c'est super
intéressant et ça c'est des très grosses
forces effectivement de huawei et comme
je voulais dit il y à 499 euros 99 et
vous j'avais des offres en ce moment et
vous avez des offres de noël vous mais
bien évidemment le lien en bas par la
description comme ça vous saurez tout
alors verdict est ce que ce smartphone
est intéressant alors il ya des trucs
que je trouve vraiment vraiment
intéressant ce smartphone à savoir la
légèreté la finesse le très grand écran
pour contenus multimédias je trouve
performant on peut venir jouer très
facilement la petite question à venir se
poser elle est très personnelle elle est
pour vous et dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire sa smart
phone qui permet pas d'avoir de la 5g
est ce que vous voulez de la 5g de votre
smartphone est ce que vous avez un
abonnement 5 g ou est ce que vous pensez
en prendre entre si c'est le cas ce
n'est peut-être pas le smartphone qu'il
vous faut si par contre vous ne vous
intéressez pas particulièrement à la 5
gt vous préférez jouer au wifi vous avez
du wifi 6 donc ça ira très très bien
c'est vraiment le premier pan le plus
important c'est un smartphone qui est
aussi orienté photo avec le capteur
principal qui nous intéressait le plus
avec la macro et le reste c'est un peu
en dessous c'est vraiment le capteur
principal qui va venir faire le boulot
ici autonomie bonne de la recharge
rapide donc ça c'est extrêmement
rassurant et puis l'expérience logiciel
si vous voulez d'internet y va ce qui se
fait aujourd'hui sur marché et bien vous
avez un truc est vachement intéressant à
vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez en
bas au commentaire est ce qu'il vous
botte sonova nage moi je trouve très
chouette bien réussi en fait plus de la
part de rui marques et sabine évidemment
pas aux commentaires on se retrouve très
très très très vite pour continuer à
parler tech et la chanteraine préparer
des bus 2022 on part au cms à las vegas
si tout se passe bien si la situation
sanitaire permet vous emmène à vegas et
vous allez voir qu elle coule des bisous
et métaux
[Musique]
je